reject nation it's an exciting time to
be a spider-man fan
very excited about this if you guys did
not catch that leaked trailer that i
think sony did come out and go yeah
it's ours we did a reaction that last
week pretty much confirming that the
spider-verse for the mcu spider-man 3
starring tom holland will be a
spider-verse i think i said that
sentence correctly what does it matter
guys we know what we're getting at and
we got even more
more news to talk about it's been
circling the web all day today alfred
molina
will be reprising his role as otto
octavius
arguably the best live-action villain
out of any of the spider-man movies who
have ever existed some people
say i've heard this but i actually had a
movie fights about this once the best
live action performance out of any
spider-man movie that wasn't my pick
it was actually toby mcguire but we got
some news to talk about that
as well toby speaking of toby speaking
to toby
speaking toby so amongst all the news
right now yes auto octavius supposedly
must have survived at the end of
spider-man 2. i wonder if that's why
they got sam raimi to direct doctor
strange to be like
yo can you talk to them for us hey let
them know it's cool
listen please didn't work out well for
you last time but hey we're making the
deal even sweeter
bring all your crew we'll let you cast
bruce campbell
in a cameo in every single one dude you
know that's our kevin feige impression
yeah so he's like approaches everyone
come on man come on
hey it's kevin i've got a fee he's a lot
more insecure than you guys
realize but there's more that is being
talked about speculated upon about how
andrew garfield and toby maguire that
we've been hearing for a long time how
they're going to be returning
so i hear they're probably going to
appear in the third act if i'm not
mistaken from daniel r
p k who is like the number one go-to guy
when it comes to
getting the scoops sometimes he's right
sometimes he's
wrong but hey the important part to take
from this is
sometimes he's right here's what he says
today andrew and dunst
they have signed uh andrew garfield
kiersten dunst they have signed on which
is exciting stuff
toby maguire and emma stone still in
talks
not signed on yet emma stone she's just
had a baby so maybe that could be
creating some type of
conflict there put the baby in the movie
daniel rpk is hearing
the baby might as well just throw them
all in there
the whole family everyone's in the movie
why not when asked do you know what's
holding up toby maguire from signing he
said money he wants a lot of money
now here's what i gotta say didn't the
man just get divorced recently
of course he wants a lot of money who
wouldn't
he needs a lot of money he's got things
to pay for
damn he needs money to fix the damn door
that's why they're here all day
good job i'll also say too that out of
anyone that they've been courting and
all the exciting
things that we've been hearing about
people who are going to be returning for
this
there was no individual there was no
individual
way more than andrew garfield that
people would be more excited
to see appear in this than tobey maguire
if
anyone's in the position right now to be
like well
i did start this whole thing off with my
boy sam raimi
let's face it guys out of any names that
are being dropped
whose majority of people are going to be
most excited for it's going to be toby
mcguire
so he does have the ultimate bargaining
chip right now this bargaining ship
being i'm [ __ ] toby mcguire
mcguire the original peter berger
i'm the thing you've rebooted twice how
are you doing and yeah i mean i think no
matter what they're gonna find a way to
get him involved
in this and i i so i find it funny
because tom maguire hasn't really been
in the spotlight for any movies in so
many years
but this is his one chance he has to be
in this position
i know i haven't seen toby mcguire i
think literally since watching the
spoils of babylon a handful of years ago
which is not spider-man caliber so i
mean i i hope that this doesn't result
in some kind of what we don't need you
situation because that would be truly
heartbreaking but yeah i mean
given the position he's in and how
hollywood works i'm sure he's got
wiggle room to drive that price up
but i gotta say i gotta say
i actually think all this [ __ ] is
already done probably
actually i think all this is already
done you know why
because they've already been filming
spider-man three yeah
and i feel like no one's talking about
that they've already been filming the
damn movie what do you think they're
just gonna
like rewrite all this at the last minute
they finally
signed on a week before rap well we
gotta rewrite some stuff guys chalk
all that other footage out because we
got toby finally because i mean i'm kind
of forgetting some of how the
the story went when it came to getting
the spider-man agreement for civil war i
know
kevin feige fought tooth and nail
because the russo brothers really didn't
want to do it any other way and they and
they got him on board
close too yeah think about it man it's a
scene it's
i mean yeah it's like a 15 20 minutes
he's in that film this is
to me this is something that has to
really
come on do i really need to add words to
this guy spiritually
you can't just willy-nilly be like hey
alfred molina said yes
i guess let's do another rewrite like
yeah i i have to believe too that with
the amount of speculation on this
specific
like we've been talking about toby
maguire andrew garfield and peripheral
spider-man cast members
for months now and there hasn't been a
the mic is on don't worry guys hasn't
been a great deal of
pushback from the powers that be to
discourage us from talking about this
either
so honestly i do have to believe that
they probably just haven't officially
announced it but these people are
already probably getting ready or if not
already having been on set i think
they're having fun with us
i think they're having some fun with us
i think all this is already squared away
it's like people have been already
hearing rumors about are we going to get
a train
last week are we going to get a trailer
or maybe in december well this this
coming thursday we're going to
disney doing its thing are we going to
get a trailer look
by now if he's on board he's on board
and they did already
leak that leak already happened so as
much as we're talking about like we're
here in mcguire
stone i really think mcguire is already
on board and we just haven't gotten the
confirmation yet
especially that's just my belief imagine
yeah that's my belief and that's what my
source says
that's what i saw you guys said that too
all you got to say my source says and
everyone thinks you're credible
my sources say if you got a sword if you
don't got a source like who are you got
a source i mean you just spit it you
just
[ __ ] at this point what are you
reading facts that have been
verified by like five other people you
need a source all right
then you never have to credit where your
information comes from my god
and now i'm just waiting to hear what
the hell this movie's actually gonna be
about
it hey yeah that would be i mean this is
certainly doing wonders for the hype
train i feel like they almost don't ever
have to confirm any of this because it's
just gonna keep us
all true in the higher training you know
very true
guys either way alfred molina being on
board i'm excited about that i mean
we're getting like electro
you know batman's michael keaton i mean
i've had
yeah you know yeah you know ryan
is gonna come back green lantern for
this movie right now
yeah everyone's gonna be there where are
you why aren't you in the movie all
right guys leave your thoughts down
below thanks for being here subscribe
click that notification bell
i'm excited about this i hope you are
too last but not least
john you wanted to shout out maria
hammond so
take it away john oh maria guess what i
i just heard from my source
you've been cast in spider-man 3 as
well they want you to be aunt may but
also the secret agent badass aunt may so
uh
if you haven't received the script yet i
don't know what you're doing
because you're due on set any minute now
okay and
by the time you see this video it's
probably going to be too late for you
and i want you to miss this opportunity
to launch your acting career and to
bring all those hard
one years of wisdom to the big screen
all right you're gonna have three
generations of toby's i mean of peters
parker to look out for so
bring your a game i believe in you and
uh it's gonna be all right you're gonna
kill it says my source says the source
all right john let me show you how it's
done now oh yeah well maria
you have been unconditionally supportive
to us for such a long time and with it
being the holiday season
i just wanted to say thank you you're
part of the reject family i know you got
your own family grown to take care of
and while there can be some strifes and
conflicts within there from time to time
i hope this holiday season you're able
to spend some real
quality time and cherish some love with
all of them because that's what matters
more than anything else
so merry christmas to you and i hope you
have a happy new year this holiday
season
that's how you do it i'm stupid stupid
stupid gosh i'm sorry maria
sincerity john